[موسيقى]
هندسه معماريه فريده من نوعها وتاريخ عريق
وتراث استثنائي
اكثر بكثير بمجرد مكان للعيش بل كنزا يجب
الحفاظ عليه باي ثمن قريه سانتا طونينو في
جزيره كورسيكا واحده من هذه الاماكن شيدت
في القرن التاسع كحصن منيع ضد البربر
والغزاه الاسبان وصرت القريه اليوم رمزا
للسكينه والجمل اوليفيي يطلع الزوار على
خبايا المكان
من حولنا مكان مهيمن بالفعل محاط بالاسوره
وهنا نرى مجموعه من الاثار القديمه وخاصه
منظرا بانوراميا يمكن مشاهدته من جميع
الزوايا
جنه صغيره تحمل اسم اجمل قريه في فرنسا
فضل البعض عدم مغادرتها ابدا في سن 22 ظل
فانسون الشاب الوحيد المتبقي في القريه
بمساعده والده يقوم بجني الزيتون في
الشباك على الطريقه التقليديه عمل شاق
نوعا ما بفضله ظلت هذه الارض على قيد
الحياه
عندما انتهي من عملي اقوم بتنظيف المكان
جيدا فيحظى ذلك باعجاب كبار السن الذين
يعرفون جيدا عمل الحقول
فتامرني السعاده لهذا الامر
حياتي كلها في هذا المكان
الكثير من الاشخاص ياتون الى القريه لاول
مره انها اجمل قريه في كورسيكا بل في
فرنسا
على الجانب الاخر من فرنسا تعتبر قريه
بونتافان في منطقه البريطان مصدر فخر
لسكانها هنا استقر الرسام وانشا مع فنانين
اخرين مدرسه
هو الاخر سحره منذ مده جمال هذه القريه
حدث احيانا ان انعزلت تماما على ضفاف نهر
افان ومن حولي لا يوجد سوى طائر مالك
الحزين الرمادي وكثير من الهدوء والسكينه
انها لحظات استثنائيه على كل حال كل يوم
مختلف عن الاخر لذلك يجب الاعتماد على
الاضواء هنا مثلا نحن امام اللون الرمادي
المزرق قليلا الوان ساحره وضعت بونطافان
بينما صافي اجمل القرى الفرنسيه والهمت
اجيالا من الرسامين لم اعرف اين ذهبت انه
مكان رائع
جاكلين زوجه كريستيانو ولدت هنا منذ صغرها
لا تحتك سوى بالفنانين كانت امي احيانا
تطلب مني شراء الخبز فانتهز الفرصه لذهاب
الى بعض القاعات حيث تقام معارض للرسم
مجانا على طول نهر افانت تسافر بنا جاكلين
عبر الزمن قبل قرنين بالضبط كان يقدم
فنانون من هنا من فرنسا ومن امريكا ومن
انجلترا للبحث عن الالهام على هذه الضفاف
كانوا يقيمون في هذا النزل
[موسيقى]
كانوا يذهبون للرسم طوال اليوم وفي المساء
يعودون غالبا ما كانوا يعرضون اعمالهم على
جدران النزل
رسوماتهم وكي يناقشوها وينتقدوا بعضهم
البعض ويستمتع بذلك طبعا
استوحى من هذه المنازل رسمه لوحته
وفي هذه الورشه وضع ملامح لوحته
طالما كانت مصدره الهام فائق الجمال
لاولئك الفنانين
[موسيقى]
نتوجه الان الى الريفيرا الفرنسيه جنوبا
حيث صنعت نباتات الخزامى والقسوس وعصافير
الجنه واشجار الميموزا شهره هذه القريه
لؤلؤه صنفت من بين اجمل القرى المزهره في
فرنسا يعود الفضل في ذلك كثيرا الى شغف
هذا الرجل
عندما بدات زرع الازهار والورود في هذه
القريه طلب مني رئيس البلديه ان اقوم
بالمزيد كان ذلك عام 64 رغبت حينها في
انشاء مكان مغاير تماما لكل من يزور قريه
بوغم زرع الرجل ايضا انواعا غير محليه
كزهار الكركديه هذه القادمه من الصين تعود
الى عام 65 موقع قريه بورم يسمح بزراعه
الازهار نظرا لقربها من البحر توجد على
ارتفاع 100 متر فوق سطح البحر في الاسفل
يوجد فرق خمس درجات مقارنه بالقريه
في عام 1970 منح المجلس الوطني للقرى
المزهره قريه بورما الجائزه التقديريه
الكبرى فتربعت على عرش الجمال منذ ذلك
الحين وحتى تحافظ على بريقها تنظم مسابقه
سنويه لافضل بستان وتخصص لها اكثر من 100
الف يورو
فازت مرتين وتود خوض المنافسه من جديد
لابد من سقيها وازاله الازهار التي ذبلت
حديقه ترى من بعيد ولا ينقصها اي شيء هذا
ما تطلبه لجنه التحكيم التي تمر على
الحدائق دون علم اصحابها
توجد لدي ازهار القطيفه وازهار البيتونيا
التي تظهر جيدا الامر مكلف كم يكلفك
تهيئتها كل سنه 500 يورو على الاقل
ايا كان الثمن تسع ماري روز جاهده كي تكون
حديقتها الابهى بين الحدائق وقريتها اجمل
قريه في فرنسا
[موسيقى]